supplied was a serial entrepreneur
wasn't age yes five isn't one for
sitting back and not starting up a
business so there was already some plans
are for for a mobile version of the
spectrum that he here wanted to bring
out what under under the project name
penned over once he was free of the
shackles of Sinclair research he started
up a new company Cambridge computers and
they come out with these n88
which is a SAT based machine the same as
all in the other spectrum range it was
yes and it's a cheap reliable good
decent processor so yes they were tried
and tested well there was quite a few
changes which you made with this one so
for example it does actually run BBC
basic as opposed to the old Sinclair
basic but it's also got built-in EPS for
or there's the the word processing
spreadsheet davi calendar is all
enclosed in one app so that's actually
really really good bit of software there
as I am Obul type device in its own
right it was groundbreaking you could
actually do do computing on the move so
my dream is it's a word processor and
it's a spreadsheet and it's a calendar
it's everything all in one it is
actually really good flexible way of
doing doing business documents as
opposed to a set for Word document a
separate excel you can actually embed
everything all in one package there it's
the ideal machine for commuting into
London by train you can see they want to
try and you can do do your work on there
you can plug it into a modem when you
get home and up load your data back to
the office it is quite flexible for
things like that this came out in 1987
and at the time I think it retailed for
399 pounds which was probably a little
bit over the price of what people wanted
to pay and it didn't didn't go on to
huge success but yeah to consider the
kind of specs now in
in terms in terms of no iPads well
you've got a 10 inch screen you've got
physical keyboard you've got built-in
apps there were other companies which
made and sold their own software for it
and there's the software packages you
can get to upload data between there and
your PC so you can copy your fire was to
it there's a plug in memory cards for
saving your date or loading new new
applications on there those are solid
state so there's either a vamp trip or
chip in there there's three sockets
under there and you can get it to
communicate easily with other things the
the battery lasts for just over 24 hours
in continuous use or up to a month on
standby
yes Sinclair c5 it's a new part there's
no transport yes I've got one loading -
Gary just bill by the way we coded
things like a spectrum on a TV with it
RF aerial okay no I was wearing glasses
for years and years and it was because
of things like that right if you are so
blind if you actually go back
[Music]